okay I don't yet have new polling about
how Joe Biden's formal announcement that
he's running for president has impacted
his standing in the 2020 Democratic
primary but we do have fundraising
numbers from Biden's first 24 hours and
he's raising a lot of money now why is
he raising a lot of money is what
matters and we'll get to that in a
second but in his first 24 hours after
his presidential announcement Joe bide
raised more money than any other 2020
Democratic candidate in their first 24
hours now there are some caveats and
we're going to discuss them I told you
on Thursday when we talked about Joe's
announcement that politics aside this is
the biggest shake-up to the race since
Bernie Sanders announced that he was
getting in and one of the impacts of Joe
Biden's announcement is that a lot of
the other centrist Democrats are just
instantly dead in the water right if
your hip Hickenlooper if you are a Cory
Booker or Amy Klobuchar or Huyen Castro
or Kirsten Gillibrand and you were sort
of hoping to be the safe center-left
moderate democratic vote Joe Biden
entering absolutely crushes and destroys
you but there's still the question of
okay is Joe Biden going to be able to
raise money and so far the answer is yes
Joe Biden raised six point three million
dollars in his first 24 hours after
announcing this came from 96 thousand
people with an average donation of 65
bucks for comparison beto raised 6.1
million in his first 24 hours and Bernie
raised 5.9 million in his first 24 hours
now what is very different about Joe
Biden than Bernie Sanders less different
than Beto or Warrick
but very different from Bernie is that
Joe Biden is raising money from very
different people than Bernie Sanders for
example Thursday night Joe Biden went to
a fundraiser hosted by Comcast's
executive vice president he has a big
Google fundraiser coming up in May with
Google's CEO Bernie on the other hand
had way more individual donors about
225,000 and those verse
24 hours so this is exactly as predicted
Biden is a centrist Democrat he's more
in line with Hillary Clinton Bernie
Sanders is not so it's not a criticism
although I lean more in the Bernie
direction than the Biden direction but
Democrats need to understand that we're
kind of in a tough place here because we
need to talk about this I'm going to
talk about how Democratic candidates are
funded I did a story about beto or Roark
removing that no lobbyists pledge from
his website Here I am telling you how
Joe Biden is funded but the write is
very clever and the write is already
using these differences to play up
internal divisions within the Democratic
Party Fox News immediately wrote an
article about how Elizabeth Warren is
slamming Biden for his swanky private
fundraiser so let's vote our policy
let's start thinning the field which is
going to start happening soon but let's
do it in a way that doesn't hurt us in
November because otherwise it's another
four years of Trump and we learned since
2016 that Trump and Hillary were not the
same they would not have governed the
same way the Supreme Court is a great
example so we need to make sure we're
striking a reasonable balance between
I'm going to tell you who's funding
Bernie who's funding kamala who's fight
funding Joe Biden and Beto and everybody
else but we need to do it in a way that
is not sort of piggybacking on and
allowing the right to further internal
strife within the Democratic primary
because the the the end result of that
is another four years of Donald Trump
and we just we just can't afford it in
the literal sense in the proverbial
sense and we've got to be really careful
about it but so far joe biden raising a
lot of money from fewer donors larger
average donation and some large
corporate fundraisers as well which is
not a surprise we knew that if Joe Biden
announced that's who he was going to be
raising a lot of money from and he is it
doesn't change anything
we just need to decide what it is that
we want